was ist über die kokain vergangenheit
von meinem vater denke dass er das alles
so geschafft hat dass er nicht irgendwo
eine verletzung hat wenn sie es will
kann sie es ich will dass ich würde
sogar erlauben
und wenn das so wäre und sie wird mich
frauen und wird sagen kann zu mir was
reine so und soja würde ich machen
es gab immer koks schon los ich hatte
das beste wir haben teilweise auf ein
schlag 70 kilo überholt er hat sich gut
verkauft in den kreisen wo kokain
konsumiert wurde von ärzten über presse
journalisten sowieso alle durch die dich
weil dann alle das heißt es war ein das
war sauber wir mussten das gar nicht
mehr schneiden wir haben das einfach nur
aus kaum übers geholt bleiben my name is
trouble inc manche nämlich den steg
könig und ich war kokain hat in
deutschland viele sagen
groß ist auch ein durch nummern
[Musik]
ich war damals ein adrenalin-junkie ich
habe die ganze welt gesehen ich habe
eigentlich alles mögliche erlebt und es
geht ich kann es nicht mehr toppen
das heißt ich habe auch jetzt ein alter
erreicht wo ich ruhiger geworden bin
meinte riesch runtergegangen
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt seit vier jahren aus knast
ich habe in hamburg versucht nach meiner
entlassung eine wohnung zu bekommen gab
es nämlich nur blockiert da habe ich
gemerkt dass die polizei irgendwie
beschattet macht den habe ich
wahrscheinlich irgendwann mal auf die
füße getreten den ein oder andern und
dienen der nachtragend und hab ich
gedacht da gehst nach bremen
[Musik]
ronald miehling wird am 12 juli 1950 in
hamburg geboren sein vater max ist
polizist seine mutter else hausfrau 1959
com thron als bruder ralf zur welt die
kinder wachsen behütet in einem
mehrfamilienhaus im stadtteil barmbek
auf die eltern versuchen ihnen alles zu
ermöglichen
so schildert es auch else miehling in
einem interview vom 12 dezember 2002 ich
habe meine kinder das los schön gemacht
ich hatte führerschein gemacht haben
auto gekauft und wenn sie aus der schule
kam sind wir immer einsamer nach der
ostsee und habe mir kann man kennt ja
nicht bieten luft und gutes essen und
liebe alles verdacht also meine kindheit
war sehr glücklich weil meine mutter war
zornig glocke um mein vater war eine ich
dir wurde kohl geeinigt hat immer gesagt
guck mal wenn du irgendwas macht er war
polizist wenn du irgendwas macht er
natürlich erwischen und ansonsten
knaster muss mit leben
doch der behütete familienalltag behling
er will raus aus hamburg barmbek das
konservative leben hinter sich lassen
ich bin aufgewachsen in einer straße da
haben british nur polizisten gefängnis
leute also jetzt bedienstete überall
waren die stars beschäftigt und wenn ich
dann in den 50er jahren gesehen habe
wenn die am sonntag dann ihre autos
geputzt haben und zu dieser
gelsenkirchener barock geherrscht hat
und diesem eine frau im pelzmantel deine
hat noch kein meine autos größer
das ist mir so auch sänger gegangen hab
gedacht das ist nicht dein leben so und
irgendwann hat sich das so ergeben habe
ich gesagt kriminalität hat er in wohn
reiz und dann habe ich das auch gemacht
um eine der miehling besonders gut kennt
ist wolfgang hier
er ist 15 jahre alt als er ronald 1965
kennenlernt sie werden beste freunde
wolfgang gibt ihm den spitznamen blacky
wegen seiner vollen schwarzen haare
lippi war so ein sympathischer typ
kameradschaftlich irgendwie dass die
chemie stimmt gleich also bei uns beiden
wird viel zusammen erlebt das zeug
gemacht wir haben gelacht und ja das war
einfach schön da bin ich da ist wir
haben uns immer gegenseitig angezogen
fotografiert er wollte aber die lange
unterhose ganze das weiß ich noch
so sind wir mit den ersten baum gefahren
natürlich nicht immer aber nein zweimal
ja da haben wir draußen im winter
trainiert das ändert sich die füße
festgefroren und wurde aber leider habe
ich nicht mehr die vier jahre waren
schon intensiv blacky ist ein
draufgänger nicht gerne die regeln 1968
begeht er seine erste straftat schwerer
raub die tat stellt auch die
freundschaft zu wolfgang beer auf eine
harte probe
das erste mal vier wochen schillerstraße
hat er die jugendarrestanstalt dieses
schon heftig für das sollte den
jugendlichen abschrecken irgendwas zu
machen
und da ist das denn jeden dritten tag
gab es nur trocken brot da musste die
matratze ausgepackt werden gab es ein
holzbrett und sodann waren nur eine
stunde freigang im kreis und man durfte
sich mit ihm unterhalten und als er da
raus kam da hat man schon so gemerkt
dass da gedacht hat so ich bin jetzt
irgendwie der verbrecher oder so und
dann aber nachher war das mit dem
schlachter gemacht hatte da war ja schon
die zahlen vorher schon dass das doch
schon erzielt hat nicht direkt
einzelheiten aber das war und dies und
das
am ersten mai 1978 wird der hamburger
fleisch großhändler manfred hering tot
in seinem haus im niedersächsischen
rheindorf aufgefunden
der 45 jährige wird von mehreren kugeln
aus nächster nähe in kopf und bauch
getroffen die tatwaffe ein us karabiner
30 m2 die verdächtigen ein betonbau und
ein koch sind ronald miehling und sein
freund jens als sie den unternehmer
ausrauben wollen lösen sich die
tödlichen schüsse das büro ich wirklich
und das ist das ist eigentlich das
schwarze flecken analysiere ich
beruhigte uns gar nichts über das tor
und 1980 wird blacky wegen fahrlässiger
tötung zu zehn jahren haft verurteilt
sein komplize jens w bekommt 15 jahre
wegen totschlags
blacky und sein freund wolf kann dir
gehen fortan getrennte wege
das verbrechen besiegelt das endgültige
ende ihrer jahrelangen freundschaft so
lange vorbei und ist das hat wehgetan
schlimm
ich komme schon wieder hoch
und dann war es nicht mehr merkte man
also dass es zu höherem berufen
mit 40 jahren kommt energie frei im
gefängnis hatte er enge kontakte zur
holländischen kokain-affäre geknüpft
sein erstes drogengeschäft lässt nicht
lange auf sich warten als tourist
getarnt steigt er am 10 august 1989 in
ein flugzeug in seinem koffer über
10.000 d-mark von hamburg aus geht es
auf die 8191 kilometer entfernte
karibikinsel curacao das
einkaufsparadies für cook stieler
[Musik]
der erste deal gewinner die leckere
gemacht haben das war so stümperhaft
lach ich heute immer noch darüber
also wäre darüber geflogen wir hatten
zwar ein kontakt den habe ich die rede
gestellt dass wir was kaufen konnten
seine zwei kilo gekauft sondern saßen
wir im hotel die zwei kinder lagen auf
dem tisch und wir haben mitmischen wird
gefeiert und wir haben schon den gewinn
gefeiert
und irgendwann das war kurz vorm abflug
fiel uns dann ein ja wir müssen das ja
auch noch rüber bringen
das muss ja irgendwie auch wenn nach
deutschland denn wir hätten gar kein
plan wir haben null plan gehabt so und
irgendwann sagte eine art pass auf ich
hoffe dass die sortenreinen alter sohn
koffer und nimmt mit dem ersten
transport wäre alle geschwitzt und der
das im kopf einer meisten geschwitzt
aber wir waren ja europäischen besoffen
deswegen haben wir es nicht so
mitgekriegt so und dann sind wir durch
durch den ersten zoll durch das rein
curacao
da sind wir so gut ruhig sondern dass
mein flieger aber in deutschland wurden
wir ja alle wieder nüchtern und dann
haben wir überlegt wie kriegen wir das
jetzt durch ja nichts anderes möglich
als probieren und ging durch das war ein
riesiges gefühl man hat einfach wie
damals an
man hat eben was erreicht das kann man
alles kann man nicht beschreiben das
einfach nur glücksgefühle
[Musik]
für seine ersten zwei kilo kokain hatte
blacky in der karibik 9000 d mark
bezahlt in deutschland verkauft er das
gramm für 80 d-mark an seine kunden pro
kilo macht er über 50.000 thema gewinn
seine kunden stammen aus der hamburger
high society
anfang der neunziger jahre die hatten
alle gilt die haben alle gearbeitet das
war alles so war von ärzten über die
auch presse journalisten sowie duale
durch den ball an alle rechtsanwälte die
teilweise ich weiß nicht was alles es
gab immer koks schon los ich hatte das
beste das heißt es war ein das war
sauber beamten nur wir mussten das gar
nicht mit schweigen
wir haben das einfach so raus kaum übers
geholt haben fortan geht blacky in der
szene als könig des kokains vom
polizistensohn zu hamburgs drogendealer
nummer eins blacky vergrößert sein
imperium schritt für schritt jeder
kokain transport aus der karibik wird
akribisch geplant er lässt sogar
spezielle koffer mit doppeltem boden
anfertigen
so schafft er es in kürzester zeit immer
größeren mengen kokain nach deutschland
zu schmuggeln werden ja eine
fluggesellschaft machen können so wie so
viele plätze gehabt und so für hotels
gibt bild mit kurieren wir haben
teilweise auf einen schlag 70 kilo immer
lohnt per flieger ich hatte die tasche
und transportieren können dass werte kam
und war weg
wehling macht millionen und genießt sein
leben in vollen zügen
er kaufte sich teure luxus limousinen
logiert in suiten von fünf-sterne-hotels
und feiert ausschweifende partys
gelegentlich haben es krachen lassen
aber nicht offiziell aber ich bin jetzt
nicht losgelaufen habt ihr euer prinz
gemacht habe ich bin ich der größte
das haben wir im ausland gemacht auch
den behörden viel blackies gehobener
lebensstil zu damaliger zeit auf über
den schnellen erfolg und den raschen
aufstieg des schneekönig zeigten sich
selbst erfahrene drogen ermittler
überrascht
auch die hamburger zollfahnder
beschäftigten sich damals intensiv mit
dem fall
blacky miehling für hamburg hatte halt
eine rolle gespielt er hat sich gut
verkauft
persönlich gut verkauft in denen kreisen
wo kokain konsumiert wurde
ich glaube nicht auch nach dem was ich
von den älteren kollegen gehört habe die
damals gegen ihn ermittelt haben dass er
eine eine wirkliche größe gewesen ist
der kokainschmuggel damals war was ganz
anderes als heute
damals war kokain als solches noch gar
nicht so verbreitet kokain war anfang
der 90er noch immer so eine schickimicki
droge die droge der reichen und schönen
aber nicht in der breiten masse so
vertreten damals haben wir noch sehr
viel mehr mit heroin
und so weiter zu tun gehabt mit
haschisch marihuana deswegen hat
kokainschmuggel damals noch gar nicht so
sehr die rolle gespielt und vor allen
dingen nicht in den größenordnung wie
sie heute vorherrschen kokain
hauptumschlagplatz der droge ist
südamerika hier wird das weiße pulver in
einem mehrstufigen produktionsverfahren
aus den blättern des koka strauches
gewonnen
von kolumbien peru und bolivien aus wie
die droge in die ganze welt exportiert
in den ersten jahren des kokain booms
anfang der 80er jahre nutzen die
südamerikanischen drogenhändler vor
allem die karibik als zwischenstation
von hier aus transportieren sie ihre
ware weiter nach nordamerika anfang der
90er jahre beginnen die kartelle den
europäischen markt mit kokain zu
überschwemmen
die südamerikanischen drogenbarone
wollen so ihre milliarden- gewinne
weiter ausbauen
gleichzeitig verstärkt die usa ihre
kontrollen
die fahnder beschlagnahmen immer größere
mengen kokain die kartelle erschließen
neue handelsrouten mit europa
einschließlich deutschland finden sie
schließlich einen lukrativen markt bis
heute wie viel kokain wurde geschmuggelt
das lässt sich so nicht ganz einfach
sagen ich kann als person die ich im
reiseführer eventuellen pfleger bin in
meinen koffer was spielen und dann kann
ich vielleicht zehn oder auch 15 kilo
schmuck habe ich aber einen ganzen
schiffscontainer voll mit ware ist es
eine ganz andere mengen da reden wir
heute aktuell von schmuggel mengen bei
500 kilo liegen das kann natürlich kein
einzelner reisen mitnehmen
heute boomt der schmuggel und handel mit
kokain in europa und deutschland
lange schon ist das weiße pulver keine
luxus droge mehr
mittlerweile greifen menschen aus allen
sozialen schichten zum kokain laut dem
aktuellen drogenbericht konsumierten
2009 10 schätzungsweise 4,3 millionen
europäer das rauschgift auch der zoll in
hamburg beschlagnahmt immer häufiger und
immer größere mengen an schmuggelware
aus südamerika der zoll hat letztes jahr
2009 10 fast zehn tonnen kokain
sichergestellt
in rotterdam und antwerpen waren die
zahlen noch um ein vielfaches größer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja auch schön entspannt kochen das wie
bilder malen das ist schön entspannt wir
mit knast immer gekocht und irgendwann
kommt so immer weiter rein und
irgendwann ist alles noch mal seinen
lebensmittelpunkt hat blacky miehling in
bremen gefunden hier wohnt er mit seiner
frau ines und tochter miriam die 17
jährige schülerin kennt die kriminelle
vergangenheit ihres vaters
er hatte ihr vor jahren behutsam von
seinen verbrechen berichtet was ich über
die kokain vergangenheit von meinem
vater denke dass er das alles so
geschafft hat dass er nicht weil sie
nicht irgendwo eine verletzung hat die
jetzt acht jahre später immer noch hat
sondern mit 70 doch kein cola tor
braucht noch kein gehweg keine lüftung
um die treppen zu bekommen oder dass er
das hat alles noch schafft also ich
glaube im kopf als er noch so ein
bisschen 270 nicht 50 probieren
[Musik]
und auch beim thema kokain wurde miriam
nichts verheimlicht miriam weiß was
kokain ist wie es wirkt und was man da
auch mit anstellen kann und dass auch
eine ganze menge geld bringt und sie hat
von anfang an gesagt nun ist nicht meins
da hab ich nichts mit zu tun ich kann
mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen dass das
merian kornfeil wenn sie es will kann
sie es ich will dass ich würde es eher
sogar erlauben
und wenn das so wäre und sie wird mich
fragen und wird sagen kann zu mir was
reine so und soja würde ich machen
[Musik]
slacker kokain 10 in deutschland gut da
hat sich viel geändert wirklich sehr
viel seit meiner bestzeit früher war das
eigentlich so dass viele deutsche das
gemacht haben und das waren alles kleine
clubs die irgendwo zwischen gedealt
haben
heute ist das sehr organisiert curacao
war eigentlich holland in warm und auf
diese insel ging unheimlich fehler das
war ja noch credo kleinkrämerei das war
sehr viel arbeit für verhältnismäßig
wenig gewinnen
die schönste zeit ist endlich gewesen wo
sie gehen also das war abenteuer pur
zum ersten mal schaffte es der
schneekönig zugang zu den berüchtigten
drogenkartellen zu bekommen eine welt
der auftragsmorde korruption und
milliardenschweren deal blacky wird ein
teil von ihr
und dann haben wir uns die polen auf der
straße glaube ich keine ahnung 30 kilo
übergeben
die gestohlenen boden wenn man sich der
verhaftung entziehen will dann kann man
überlegen ob man verkehrsregeln einhält
da kann man auch nicht überlegen wie
gefährlich das ist dann auch an gas
geben dann kam der irgendwann hat auch
eine reiche hätten angebote für
wohnliche raum bekommt den usa wo
identität darf nicht mehr nach europa
zurück dafür muss natürlich dein wissen
preisgeben
er geht den weg bis zum ende schneekönig
verbleibende lebende legende
[Musik]
und wenn der schnee schmilzt der nächste
winter kommt bestimmt geschwächelt
er geht den weg bis zum ende bleiben wir
lebende legende schlägt
auch wenn es nicht selbst der nächste
winter kommt bestimmt der schneekönig
bleiben
[Musik]